last question I got for you is reference
to the um the Cooperative asset is it is
it like drop it drop out drop it okay
cool is there is there tethering do you
have to stay next to you and kid had to
kind of be or could you go
um I if there was tethering it was so
large of a skeleton okay no doubt no
doubt uh but there is I honestly
dropping and drop out but you do keep
the progression nice that's big that's
big that's the first thing I tested I
was like kid Smith I'm popping out of
here I'm see if it kept your stuff no
doubt so we got your full review going
up live after the show you know what I'm
saying Premiere you so go stick around
for that it should be some good content
also Lord go to loads of gaming.net
because we got our review up there as
well my man magic Gene you know what I'm
saying had his thoughts on it